This is Startalk we're back star talk
radio this is the how tweeted is segment
Bill Nye joining me here so good to have
you in you tweet at Bill Nye I do it's
very nice so here we analyze tweets I've
posted and look at the behind the scenes
and people's reactions and there's one
bill
Neil: It is the most retweeted tweet I've ever posted.
Bill: The most retweeted tweet?
Neil: People went bananas. Ape bananas, okay?
Christmas Day, here is my tweet.
Bill: Oh, the 25th of December.
Neil: On this day long ago, a child was born who,
by age 30, would transform the world.
Happy Birthday Isaac Newton, born December 25, 1642.
I thought people might want to know!
Bill: He's reck'n in Britain.
Neil: Yeah in England he's born on December 25th. Have
you told me over the years you're born
on the day that your mother thinks you
were born on.
Bill: Well that's one way of looking at it.
The Catholic Church is crazy to tell everybody, they
just love telling everybody, but it was the 4th of January.
Neil: Well yeah, because England had
not yet... not a big fan of the
Church, the Catholic Church.
Bill: They had their own deal.
Neil: Yeah, they stayed with the Julian
calendar a little longer than others did.
Bill: A little longer - 150 years longer.
Imagine everybody what it's like if
you're trying to do commerce and you
don't agree on the calendars.
Imagine, everybody, a guy so powerful, Pope Gregory the 13th, was so
powerful he declared October 5th shall
be followed by October 15th in
1572, no, 1582. Yeah excuse me 1582,
and so you're a landlord This is great.
"Hey you owe me another month's rent!"
Neil: No, I know how to amortize.
Yeah, I know how to do the math on that one.
Bill: But I gotta think that Newton's mom
thought it was Christmas day.
Neil: So we got that, and then hence I posted this tweet
but people reacted. There was some newspaper
headline that said, "Tyson trolls Christians on
Christmas Day" and I'm thinking, don't
people want to know that there's this
guy who was actually born that day? We
don't really know when Jesus was born.
Bill: Apparently he was born four years before.
They even they lied about his age even back then.
Neil: 4 BC is probably the better date for you.
Bill: There were some comments.
Neil: There's some alignment of planets that...
people trying to find what the Wise Men
we're looking at. My point is I thought
people be enchanted by learning about
Isaac Newton and his significance in
shaping modern culture being that
basically the founder of the knowable universe.
Bill: You had somebody else in mind.
An historic figure.
Neil: I'd had other tweets that day too.
Can I tell you my favorite one from that day?
It's about Santa. I said Santa
knows physics. Red light penetrates fog
better any other color.
Bill: No matter whether the dress
is black and blue or white and gold.
Neil: So Benny the Blue-Nosed
Reindeer didn't get the gig.
I worked hard on that one.
Bill: It was good. People say, well, how do
you see Santa at
this store and at that shopping mall?
Because he's magic.
Neil: That's the answer.
Bill: Okay so what then, like, you can do that.
Neil: Oh by the people who said I was
trolling Christians, they must have
missed two days before where I
photographed the Christmas windows at
Macy's Herald Square.
Bill: Which were cool. I Tweeted a couple.
Neil: You Tweeted a couple. They're great!
Little Alex is on an interplanetary sleigh.
Bill: Yes he's intra-cosmotic.
Neil: He's visiting the planets. He's good.
We've got to wrap this. Bill,
thanks for joining me on "How Tweet It Is."
You've been listening to StarTalk Radio.
And, follow the conversation.
@StarTalkRadio on Twitter.
As always, I bid you to keep looking up.